it's a fish-eat-fish world out there and
some fish definitely have an edge with
their electrifying abilities now
scientists think they know how electric
eels use high-voltage shocks to locate
and stun their prey Vanderbilt
University's kenneth Catania filmed the
Eels predatory attacks and converted
their zaps into sound or color
as eels poke around their complicated
neighborhoods they give off low voltage
pulses that help them sense what's
around them
Catania found that the Eels quick pairs
of high voltage pulses actually help the
animals find hidden prey these pulses
travel through the water collide with
hidden fish and hack into their nervous
systems delivering messages to their
muscles that cause the fish to twitch
the twitches disturb the water ever so
slightly a vibration that the Eels can
sense and use to home in on the prey
once the eels have locked on to their
target they send out more prolonged high
voltage pulses that also hack into the
nervous system of the prey fish to
immobilize it this behavior becomes
clear in the videos where Catania
transforms the Eels pulses into a red
color you can see the prey fish become
immobilized as the eel emits its pulses
and you can see the eel then suck the
fish into its mouth Kotani explains the
electric eels remote-controlled taser
tactics in the December 5th size